[Musique]
mais d'abord la page culture dans le 7 8
on parle de nombreux sujets et notamment
de ce prix youtubeur d'histoire lycéen
2022 je lui disais tout à l'heure il a
été remis à l'occasion du salon histoire
de lire à Versailles c'est en novembre
le lauréat est avec nous en plateau
c'est Maxence de la croué qui élève de
première au lycée blanche de cassis
c'est au Chesnay Rocancourt et je le
disais tout à l'heure vous avez remporté
ce prix grâce à votre vidéo on a
toujours la patate grâce à Parmentier ça
vous fait quoi de remporter un prix
en étant un élève aujourd'hui de de
première qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de
remporter un prix bah évidemment à la
base je m'y attendais pas du tout à
recevoir ce prix mais c'est vrai que ça
ça apporte beaucoup de satisfaction
parce que ça est très compensé du
travail qu'on a fourni c'est franchement
la meilleure chose qui puisse nous
arriver comment vous avez eu vent de ce
prix et pourquoi avoir voulu y
participer alors l'année dernière on
m'avait déjà proposé de faire ce prix ça
venait d'une famille d'amis qui m'avait
proposé de le faire mais c'est vrai que
j'étais pas forcément très motivé et
puis j'étais même pas sûr j'étais même
pas sur Le Chesnay que c'est compliqué
et puis cette année on m'a relancé et je
me suis dit bon pourquoi pas c'était
pendant les vacances et donc pendant
trois jours je me suis je me suis j'ai
fait cette vidéo et puis et puis j'ai
envoyé quoi en disant pourquoi pas une
vidéo qui met en lumière Antoine
Parmentier on va regarder tout de suite
un extrait bonjour à tous j'espère que
vous allez bien on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour parler d'un homme qui a
su donner aux Français un goût pour un
aliment qui nous met tous de bonne
humeur et je parle bien sûr ici de la
pomme de terre et cet homme c'est
Antoine Augustin Parmentier Parmentier
est né en 1737 en Picardie il est issu
d'une famille très modeste il va devenir
apprenti apothicaire à l'âge de 13 ans
ses parents n'avaient pas vraiment assez
d'argent pour l'envoyer au collège il
poursuit donc sa formation et va
s'engager dans l'âge dans l'armée à
l'âge de 20 ans en tant que pharmacien
bon entre nous si les parties de l'armée
c'est pas pour faire un mec hein c'est
juste parce qu'il est pas assez d'argent
pour ouvrir sa propre pharmacie
mais au cours de la guerre des sept ans
qui a duré de 1756 à 1763 Parmentier et
capturé par les Prussiens et comme tout
adversaire militaire les Prussiens
étaient très sadiques avec leurs
prisonniers et croyez donc les déprimés
en leur servant chaque jour une bouillie
de pommes de terre mais Parmentier
s'aperçoit que sa santé ne se dégrade
pas avec ce turbir avec ce tubercule il
est d'abord donc une théorie selon
laquelle cette plante doit remplacer le
pain en France qui est donc l'aliment de
base des Français en cas de mauvaises
oiseaux Maxence votre sujet donc Antoine
Augustin Parmentier avec plusieurs
facettes celles de pharmacien de
nutritionnistes c'est surtout
d'infatigables expérimentateur au XVIIIe
siècle on lui doit notamment parce qu'il
y a aussi beaucoup d'autres travaux mais
ces travaux sur la pomme de terre qui
s'est imposée peu à peu comme un aliment
phare de la nourriture des Français
c'est un tubercule qui a été introduit
en Europe suite à la découverte de
l'Amérique mais pourquoi choisir ce
sujet le sujet Parmentier parce que la
contrainte de cette vidéo YouTube
c'était ça devait rentrer dans le
programme qu'on faisait dans des lycéens
dans laquelle on était donc moi j'étais
en première mais je savais qu'il je
devais je devais faire la différence par
mon originalité donc il fallait que je
trouve quelque chose qui soit dans la
période que je vais étudier cette année
en première et que l'on étudie pas en
classe et c'est vrai comme j'avais
étudié Antoine Parmentier dans un
magazine j'avais plutôt bien aimé son
histoire je me suis dit que c'était
c'était le sujet idéal mais ça vous a
intéressé le fait aussi de voir que au
18e siècle la pomme de terre on ne
connaissait pas forcément et aujourd'hui
quand on regarde dans la gastronomie
française ça s'est imposé comme un
aliment vraiment de base c'est vrai que
c'est assez hallucinant de voir que en
même pas trois siècles et demi la pomme
de terre a vraiment évolué dans dans
l'assiette des Français et alors
qu'aujourd'hui enfin tout le monde mange
de la pomme de terre au quotidien tout
le temps et c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
c'était pas forcément le cas et
l'évidence pour tout le monde il y a une
recette qui parle à tout le monde là je
suis Parmentier forcément un hommage à
Antoine Parmentier vous avez mener
comment vos recherches vous avez dit
c'est parti d'un magazine vous aviez lu
quelque chose un article sur Antoine
Parmentier comment vous avez mené vos
recherches pour faire cette vidéo
énormément à partir de ce magazine que
j'avais lu et conserver et puis après
des recherches internet voilà donc et
j'ai dû écrire un peu le script ce que
je voulais ce que je voulais dire il
fallait que j'aborde vraiment toutes les
facettes de sa vie et mais c'est vrai
que c'était énormément grâce à ce
magazine et vous avez découvert d'autres
choses intéressantes à son sujet au-delà
du fait que c'est le vulgarisateur de la
pomme de terre en Europe bah bien sûr
enfin c'est vrai que il y a une anecdote
surtout qui m'a énormément plu c'est le
fait que je l'explique dans ma vidéo
mais c'est que les Français étaient à
doutés sur sur la fiabilité de senpoque
de terre et il va donc placer des gardes
autour de son champ de pomme de terre
pour faire comprendre aux Français que
que c'est cette pomme de terre c'est
c'est un vrai aliment qui a de la valeur
il va aussi offrir d'ailleurs une plante
de pommes de terre au roi
entre guillemets pour pour que le
pouvoir royal certifie cette pomme de
terre et que les Français soient sûr que
c'est un aliment qui soit
de toute fiabilité donc il y a un lien
direct avec les Yvelines si ça a été
présenté dans la cour du roi
effectivement au château de Versailles
pour la réalisation de la vidéo ça s'est
passé comment est-ce que vous aviez des
notions en vidéo pas du tout c'est aussi
une découverte j'avais déjà fait oui
j'avais déjà un fond vert un micro
cravate enfin j'avais déjà moi j'aime
beaucoup j'aime beaucoup la vidéo le
montage etc donc ça c'était pas vraiment
à probable après j'avais un ami venant
de Nantes qui était là donc il était
derrière moi pour faire le cadrage
c'était plus simple pour le tournage en
gros j'ai dispatché mon travail en trois
jours premier jour écrire le script
deuxième jour faire le tournage et
troisième jour le montage ça vous a
donné envie d'en faire d'autres
peut-être
ça me donne beaucoup envie après il y a
le temps il y a le problème de temps
c'est vrai que en première on est assez
chargé etc mais c'est vrai que dès que
je pense que dès que j'aurai l'occasion
je me dirais pourquoi pas en refaire
plus une autre ou plusieurs peut-être
une carrière dans l'histoire dans aussi
une carrière de youtubeur est-ce qu'il y
a par exemple des youtubers d'histoire
qui vous inspirent peut-être est-ce que
vous en avez vous avez des références
pas spécialement des youtubeurs j'en ai
pas j'ai pas des noms mais c'est vrai
que quand je suis en cours d'histoire et
que j'ai besoin de comprendre une notion
c'est vrai que j'aime bien aller
regarder des des personnes qui
m'expliquent etc mais j'ai pas de j'ai
je ne suis pas quelqu'un en particulier
bravo en tout cas pour cette vidéo je le
rappelle le titre c'est on a toujours la
patate grâce à Parmentier on peut la
retrouver sur votre chaîne Youtube en
intégralité mais surveillez aussi un TV
78 nous la diffuserons également
régulièrement sur la chaîne mais
également sur nos réseaux sociaux merci
Maxence merci beaucoup monsieur en
plateau dans l'émission Vy P very
chinoise personne Véronique Ithurbide
reçoit et James Olin il est à la fois
colonel de gendarmerie dirigeant des
unités d'investigation mais aussi auteur
de polar aimez-vous les uns les autres
c'est d'ailleurs le titre de son dernier
roman paru aux éditions caïmans extrait
de l'émission on parle pas de romans
policiers il y a écrit polar on parle de
romon noir vous pouvez me définir un
petit peu ce genre du roman noir par
rapport au roman polo policier habituels
fourre-tout je dirais mais qui subdivise
en plusieurs plusieurs
subdivisions répétitions mais
le roman policier on va dire que c'est
le roman unique Agatha Christie il y a
un meurtre qui a colonel Moutarde devant
c'est le Cluedo il y a le roman noir
plutôt qui a une dimension sociétale qui
va
s'intéresser à un problème un problème
sociétal un peu et puis il y a le roman
noir je dirais le qui vise à faire peur
donc là c'est simple c'est comme une
sorte de film d'horreur
faut créer de la peur chez le lecteur il
y a le roman noir humoristique de façon
son Antonio etc
je me suis aperçu que je faisais deux il
y avait deux veines début je voulais
faire comme si non sinon il faisait un
truc sympa il disait il y a les maigres
c'est les romans que j'ai créé en une
semaine en si flottant et puis il y a la
les romans sérieux voilà que que je mets
du temps à les écrire bon finalement au
début je voulais faire ça puis ça va pas
c'était voilà c'était pas donc
maintenant en fait finalement il y a
deux deux catégories qui se dessinent il
y a les humoristiques un peu drôle comme
celui-là et puis plutôt sombre pour dire
qu'il y a une veine sombre et une veine
blanche un peu comme pour comme de la BD
et le précédent la pleine balle c'était
plutôt du sombre
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas trop
c'est surtout les
les personnes les individus les ressorts
individuels
émission Vy à retrouver en intégralité
sur notre site Internet TV 78.com et sur
notre application mobile et de la
musique à présent dans le 7 8 il sera
dans les Yvelines le 16 décembre
prochain Alexis HK jouera sur la scène
du théâtre Coluche de plaisir un concert
organisé par la clé des champs qui
débutera à 20h30 et Alexis HK est avec
nous par visioconférence bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous alors vous
présenterez entre autres votre nouvel
album bobo playground je vous propose
histoire qu'on se mette un petit peu
dans l'ambiance d'écouter tout de suite
un extrait cet album et on écoute un
extrait justement du titre bobo
playground le clivage jamais et
réglementaire les crevards qui dit au
pied des barres gris clair et les petits
minions qui se paient non pavillon en
fumant le pneu son guépard les maquignon
[Applaudissements]
sur le bobo les Noirs
bourgeois moyen
bonjour à beau et bien
vous êtes auteur compositeur interprète
vous avez 25 ans de carrière à votre
actif de nombreuses distinctions on peut
citer notamment celle de chevaliers des
Arts et des Lettres en 2016 vous avez
été aussi nommé dans la catégorie
Révélation révélation saine aux
Victoires de la Musique en 2012 et je le
disais vous revenez donc avec cet album
popo bobo playground dans lequel vous
vous interrogez sur sur le bonheur quel
est le message que vous allez vous avez
voulu passer dans cet album
moi je sais pas si passer des messages
c'est vraiment le rôle d'un chanteur
c'est surtout donner un regard en fait
sur les choses un regard subjectif donc
qui n'est pas forcément vrai tu peux
prêter de lieu
et c'est vrai que le clivage
les privilégiés ce qu'on appelle un peu
les bobos aujourd'hui et les autres
c'est
dans l'air du temps et c'est quelque
chose qui qui me parlait et j'avais
envie de j'avais envie de le faire comme
un troubadour c'est à dire avec
en chanson mais c'est surtout pour
parler d'écrivage en chanson avec humour
mais aussi toujours en tendresse et vous
dites vous vous moquez des des bobos
qui sont les bobos dont vous parlez ce
qu'on est pas tous un peu bobo au fond
c'est surtout de
me suis regardé vivre et je me suis
regardé vivre et je me suis dit ouais
toi si on devait être dans une catégorie
je pense que tu te prêter de beau et à
partir de là ça m'a donné envie de
reprendre un peu comme Renault à son
époque tous les clichés asiatiques
journalistique des bobos parce qu'il y a
toute une iconographie il suffit que
vous ayez un meuble design chez vous ou
une paire de beachtocks et vous pouvez
vous faire traiter de vos mots et ça ça
m'amusait pas mal mais oui
c'est une valeur
intéressante aujourd'hui puisque comme
tout est devenu un petit peu compliqué
dans le rire dans l'amusement ou dans le
dans les revenus ils vont se moquer de
soi-même d'abord je pense que c'est ce
qui marche mieux
pour pas se faire massacrer sur les
réseaux sociaux et pour pouvoir parler
des choses en disant voilà je sais de
quoi je vous parle parce que parce que
c'est moi quoi en fait
et quand on vous écoute on a
l'impression aussi que aucun mot n'est
choisi au hasard alors quand on lit
votre présentation on vous définit comme
poète funambule on a l'impression que
vous amusez avec la langue française
c'est le cas
oui je fais du texte quelque chose
d'important parce que moi je fais ouais
je suis et en chanson le texte est
primordial les mots sont très très
important
vous serez donc je le disais en concert
le vendredi 16 décembre sur la scène du
théâtre Coluche le concert débutera à
20h30 alors si on remonte le fil du
temps votre dernier show c'était un
mélange entre concerts one man show et
également à quoi doit-on s'attendre
cette fois-ci pour pour ce show à
plaisir
de cette fameuse idée de jeu pour robot
ça va être un concert basé sur le bien
et c'est un concert inspiré par les plus
grands maîtres du développement
personnel quoi c'est à dire je m'amuse
avec cette notion de bien-être puisque
c'est vraiment une notion qu'on nous
vend beaucoup aujourd'hui on le vend
d'un côté la fin du monde tous les jours
et en même temps en ouvrant le bien-être
avec plein de techniques pour rester
heureux malgré tout et donc je m'amuse
avec ça pour pouvoir vivre au milieu des
chansons
pour vous qui êtes né dans les Yvelines
si je ne m'abuse arrêtez-moi si je me
trompe je crois que vous êtes né à
Poissy c'est particulier d'aller à la
rencontre du public Yves Linois de vous
produire dans les Yvelines à chaque fois
c'est un retour aux sources c'est oui
c'est particulier parce que c'est pas
n'importe où et les Yvelines c'est chez
moi quoi c'est mes origines c'est là que
j'ai grandi moi j'ai grandi à
Verneuil-sur-Seine donc pas très très
loin de plaisir pas très loin de
Versailles et donc ouais c'est un retour
aux sources je sais que il y aura de la
famille je sais qu'il y aura peut-être
des vieux amis c'est forcément un peu
particulier et en janvier 2023 vous
retrouverez l'Olympia j'ai retrouvé
parce que vous êtes déjà produit à
l'Olympia vous avez hâte
oui j'ai retrouvé ça va être une grande
soirée
ça va être une grande soirée ou là
encore il faut profiter un maximum c'est
une chance pour n'importe quel chanteur
l'Olympia et c'est une chance qu'il faut
pas laisser passer moi j'en fais pas 5
sur 8 j'en fais 15h donc je compte bien
en profiter oui j'ai hâte tout à fait
merci Alexis HK d'avoir été avec nous
malgré une connexion un peu mauvaise ce
soir mais merci d'avoir été avec nous et
je le rappelle vous serez sur la scène
du théâtre Coluche à plaisir ce sera le
vendredi 16 décembre un concert organisé
par la clé des champs qui est débutera à
20h30 toutes les informations à
retrouver sur le site internet du
théâtre Coluche de plaisir
et on en parlait en début d'émission la
compagnie Pixum va donner un nouveau
spectacle immersif au Petit Moulin des
Vaux de Cernay ce sera du 16 décembre au
15 janvier avec nous pour en parler elle
est revenue également en plateau c'est
Charlie formant qui est directrice
artistique de la compagnie Pixum le
temps des humains c'est le nom de ce
spectacle qui se déroule en 22 2023 sur
terre c'est ça l'espèce humaine a
disparu voilà histoire de planter le
décor quel est le pitch du spectacle
j'ai quand même un petit peu planté le
décor mais comment pourrait-on me
présenter
l'espèce d'après les humains ceux qui
viendront après nous
trouvent des objets beaucoup des déchets
que on a laissé derrière nous et il se
demande bien à quoi ça peut servir donc
c'est une c'est une exposition
archéologique où l'espèce d'après les
spécialistes de l'espèce d'après se
demandent mais à quoi pouvait bien
servir tous les objets du quotidien des
humains et on les regarde on les dit
c'est qu'on se pose des questions sur à
quoi pouvait bien servir ses objets pour
les humains et profite nous artiste pour
faire passer un message écologique sur
se poser la question de tous ces objets
qui font notre quotidien et qui sont pas
forcément très utiles et très voilà très
bon pour la planète quoi derrière
j'imagine c'est aussi de pousser la
réflexion sur notre société aujourd'hui
c'est la réflexion sur notre rapport à
l'objet bien sûr notre rapport à la
nature
et notre rapport aussi aux uns aux
autres et un peu aux archétypes qui font
de notre société et comment comment on
évolue aujourd'hui société allemand
voilà on parle beaucoup de la fin du
monde est-ce qu'on peut en parler avec
le sourire est-ce qu'on peut en parler
d'une façon un peu bonne enfant qui
fasse avancer vraiment les choses de
façon interactive où on peut réfléchir
ensemble et pas de façon culpabilisante
comme on peut le voir parfois avec aussi
la découverte d'un nouveau monde un
guide d'une nouvelle espèce comment vous
l'avez imaginé cette nouvelle espèce
c'est un humain 3.0 un petit peu ouais
alors c'est on les appelle les fausses
muscles et ils sont c'est des espèces de
champignons qui ont qui ont évolué avec
une espèce de dérive plastique parce
qu'il y avait tellement de plastique sur
terre qu'ils ont leur corps évolué avec
leur un mélange de plastique et de
fondus voilà et on les appelle les
fausses muscles et ils sont très
attachants et voilà il se posent
énormément de questions sur les humains
et ils ont pas forcément tout compris
sur comment ça fonctionnait pour nous
mais ils sont ils sont très volontaires
ils sont très envie de comprendre et ils
demandent d'ailleurs au public leurs
idées sur telle ou tel objet à quoi
pouvait-il servir voilà donc nous en
tant que compagnie on a détourné
beaucoup d'objets qu'on récupère et
qu'on va mixer ensemble pour pour créer
des voilà des objets un peu curieux et
où on se pose des questions sur sur leur
utilisation dans notre vie et dans le
spectacle et on parle là d'une
expérience immersive c'est un spectacle
immersif comment justement les
spectateurs vous en avez un peu parlé
mais comment sont-ils associés justement
à ce spectacle alors nous ça sera comme
une expo en fait donc les gens arrive
comme pour une exposition sauf que quand
ils arrivent il y a une machine à
voyager dans le temps et ils sont
embarqués dans une aventure où on leur
demande d'être participant de l'aventure
on va leur poser des questions on va
leur demander leurs idées et aussi on va
lui faire participer plus physiquement
en leur demandant de ramener un objet de
chez eux qui va faire partie du
spectacle qu'ils vont laisser dans le
dans le lieu pour participer à la
construction de ce décor on voit l'image
l'un des spectacles que vous avez pu
proposer sur sur le thème d'Halloween
spectacle également immersif et on a
l'impression qu'il y a de plus en plus
de spectacles immersif on en relais
souvent dans cette émission du 7 8
pourquoi c'est intéressant justement
d'associer le spectateur qu'est-ce qui
vous intéresse maintenant je pense qu'on
est dans la précovie et que c'est
intéressant aujourd'hui de proposer
autre chose au spectateur qui
aujourd'hui on a tous nettoyé chez nous
on peut tous
regarder la télé se faire raconter une
histoire avec des effets spéciaux ça
c'est possible aujourd'hui pour tout le
monde chez soi alors aujourd'hui en tant
qu'artiste qu'est-ce qu'on propose à la
population qui va changer un peu la
donne qui fait qu'on va voir des gens
qu'on va participer à quelque chose on
va avoir une vraie expérience physique
et qu'on va partager avec d'autres
humains finalement et ça c'est une
expérience je pense que les gens
recherchent aujourd'hui la particularité
aussi de ce spectacle c'est que vous
avez mêlé théâtre danse art plastique
numérique également c'est ça ouais on
mélange plein de médias ensemble
parce qu'on a des comédiens on a des
danseuses là sur ce projet on a aussi du
chant et on a beaucoup de plasticiens
qui viennent pour créer ces décors ça a
été le cas aussi sur la maison hantée
pour Halloween ou on a un côté plastique
très très fort parce qu'on fait du
théâtre d'objets donc on récupère des
objets qu'on va avoir grâce à un
partenariat qu'on a avec la Ressourcerie
du Perray qui va nous fournir de l'objet
que nous on va revaloriser
artistiquement et qui du coup fait une
valorisation écologique de la même façon
puisqu'on récupère des objets qui
seraient voués à un autre destin et on
les on les reprend dans un circuit court
et on les on les revalorise voilà et
combien de comédiens de danseurs sur ce
spectacle
voilà dans la maison hantée ils étaient
une dizaine donc ça dépend des projets
quoi voilà donc ce sera à retrouver le
temps des humains du 16 décembre au 15
janvier les vendredi samedi dimanche et
donc au Petit Moulin des Vaux de Cernay
merci Charlie formenty et d'être venu en
parler en plateau et je le rappelle vous
êtes la directrice artistique de la
compagnie Pixon qui propose ce spectacle
d'ailleurs si vous souhaitez réserver
votre place rendez-vous sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
le billet je parle sous vos contrôle via
adulte au tarif de 5 euros pour les
enfants merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci
[Musique]